entonces hoy vamos a empezar a construir
los robots primero vamos a ver un vídeo
lo vamos a ver todos al mismo tiempo
pero cada pareja lo va a ver a su propio
ritmo para ayudarles en cada paso en
primer lugar van a desoldar la
resistencia de led y el cable negro y
cuando vean el vídeo nuevamente lo van a
entender pasa a calentar estos dos
puntos y a jalar tu led
halal o
muy bien ya quítele
y se me callo
y necesitás quitar más o menos una
pulgada y media del aislamiento de los
dos lados
espera pero no se quitó todo muy bien ya
está no lo quitamos todo parece que
rompimos la placa base así que ahora
tenemos que quitar el resto si de todas
formas lo íbamos a tirar porque no
necesitamos el foco claro que sí no
bueno ahora vamos a ver el resto del
vídeo para saber qué debemos hacer
después tenemos mucho cable así que le
ponemos cinta de aislar esto realmente
ayudará
no lo puedo abrir
aquí lo tienes
creo que lo estamos atornillando del
lado equivocado
sí
esta es la luz que va a parpadear
no tengo ni idea de qué es esto yo
tampoco a qué se parece que les recuerda
un gusano si parece una cosa del cpu de
la computadora
cuál es la regla para estos la regla es
que siempre los tengamos puestos porque
algo podría volar por el aire y caer en
tu cara y así tienes protección para
mostrarles cómo se hace y que tengan
confianza muy bien y cuando lo hicieron
se sintieron exitosos y orgullosos de
ellos mismos porque les dije que en esto
es donde yo me había esforzado más me
ayudas claro necesitas ver el vídeo
porque este nuestro siguiente paso es lo
opuesto cierto
muy bien sí buen trabajo guau genial
te importaría regresar a ver el vídeo
para saber cómo poner tus cables veo que
los números aquí están puestos para
arriba pero aquí están hacia abajo que
el lado debe estar para arriba y por qué
y dónde van los cables los cables van o
exacto y si cerramos este hueco qué va a
pasar
va a estar suelto así es entonces que el
lado debe ir para arriba perfecto y
cuantas pulgadas debe tener de
separación dos y media sí y en la parte
donde van los cables en los motores
algunos no los ponen bien así que falla
porque debe torcer el cable para que
empuje el metal en el motor pero es una
sutileza que puede perderse en el vídeo
vimos esa parte de cómo colocar el cable
y ahí fue cuando él dijo ya sé lo que
hizo ya sé lo que hizo a ok y luego él
lo pudo hacer 'lobby' torcer el cable
para ponerlo ahí el cable está retirado
así que una vez que tienes todo pegado
junto tienes que tratar de poner los
cables lo cual es muy difícil
podemos poner este de este lado
el problema es que queda muy suelto
probablemente debamos soldar lo pegarlo
con silicona y
vamos a pegarlo con silicona en su lugar
eso debe quedar bien es muy ancho para
ese agujero pero es una buena solución
muy bien nuestra me qué vas a hacer
pienso que es muy emocionante ver a los
chicos avanzar a su manera e intentarlo
y hay un par de estudiantes que no
pegaron sus cables
sino que encontraron a otros que lo
hicieran eso es una contratación todo el
tiempo han estado haciendo su
contratación han estado trabajando con
otros estudiantes y yo les dije saben
cómo pelar cables y ellos dijeron no y
entonces como han llegado hasta aquí y
dijeron que se los habían dado a otros
chicos para que lo hicieran y hay chicos
que quieren ese trabajo debes entender
qué sucede de ambos lados hay chicos que
les dicen yo lo hago por ti yo espero
que para todos esos chicos que están en
esta carrera para terminar y luego
logran terminar y la cosa no les
funciona también tengan una lección que
aprender espero que tengan tiempo para
reconsiderar y digan ok no puse
suficiente atención porque muchos de
ellos no tienen la oportunidad para
aprender de esta manera donde sean
realmente responsables y sin que alguien
siempre les diga no espera eso está mal
tienes que arreglarlo
entonces me encanta el hecho de que
estuvimos un paso atrás el día de hoy y
yo vi algunas cosas como bueno continúa
con eso a ver qué pasa la profesora que
tenemos dentro quiere ir y decirles ya
lo revisaste pero no
exacto debemos detenernos y no decir
nada pero pienso que no lo dijimos y
ellos estuvieron viendo los vídeos mucho
más y me gustó que lo hicieran que ellos
estuvieran sentados ahí seriamente si
hace que ellos tengan autocontrol sí así
es
pienso que es bueno que lo vean así es
estamos terminando el robot y después de
esto lo vamos a programar
los aislantes no permiten que la
electricidad pase a través de ellos y
los conductores conducen la electricidad
pensé que iba a ser más fácil pero me
equivoqué y eso me gustó
fue un reto si realmente fue retador y
fue divertido también qué consejo le
darías a un par de chicos que todavía no
han hecho su robot y que lo van a hacer
bueno yo les diría que trabajarán duro
sí y que no lo hicieran tan rápido
porque lo echas a perder
se ve diferente ahora que hicieron
chicas
anteriormente lo pusimos horizontal y
luego hicimos que fuera vertical
impresionante y así queda mejor cierto
si ahora queda plano muy bien buen
trabajo hoy hicimos un circuito con un
interruptor que es un circuito tenemos
que quitarle el aislamiento para que el
metal pueda cerrar el circuito
y cuando ponemos el interruptor entonces
toca la pieza de metal y cierra el
circuito y después también lo puede
abrir
este fallo cayó mira dónde debe ir esto
donde debe ir el cable negro en el
bloque terminal en el centro en el
centro porque porque en el centro estas
son nuestras cargas negativas estas son
las positivas
estos son los cables de corriente y esto
básicamente le va a decir al arduino que
hacer yo pienso no tengo la menor idea
ok ya lo tenemos ahí que más las partes
exteriores del cable las amarillas el
aislante básicamente son resistencias
que hacen que si el cable toca otro
cable los electrones no fluyan por él y
hacen cortocircuito o lo queman
y algunas veces pasa eso y se unen
guau este es tonto cada vez que quiero
mostrarle a alguien cómo funciona no
funciona si prueba su interruptor debe
encender la luz cierto qué es lo que el
interruptor hace además de prender y
apagar la luz el interruptor no
funcionaría estaría aprendido todo el
tiempo como ahora lo soltamos en el
punto equivocado dónde iba el
interruptor se supone que debería ser
aquí pero accidentalmente lo soltamos
acá
funcionará cuando los cables estén allí
pero cuando tratemos de apagarlo
simplemente se quedará prendido el
interruptor está funcionando
bueno cierre el circuito porque abierto
es cuando no funciona
la soldadura es como metal derretido
y eso pega a otras piezas de metal
es un conductor porque es metal
ok asia está bien el nuestro no quedó
pegado lo estuvimos jaloneando y se cayó
ya está pegado si está perfecto ya lo
está cubriendo todo un control de motor
controla la velocidad y la dirección del
motor qué tan rápido da la vuelta y en
qué dirección va si va hacia adelante o
hacia atrás y siempre puedes meter eso
en el programa
algo pasó estaba funcionando tú lo viste
vamos vamos robot te lo ruego está bien
mira el mío
dicho
amigo perdiste una rueda perdiste una
rueda es una tontería que pasó perdimos
una rueda y el led salió el led se salió
qué tontería
genial queremos empezar
solo déjame ver cópialo y pégalo y luego
lo va a cambiar vamos a hacer que dé
vueltas y que parpadea
y luego pelear
no porque no
vamos
dónde está mi escudo dónde está mi
escudo
te hice para ganar no para perder
mira vez esto se ve bonito es como un
sable de luz sí cierto o es grandioso
aquí lo que tenemos que hacer es poner
básicamente lo terminamos hoy y no
tuvimos suficiente tiempo así que lo
tuvimos que pegar con cinta y no
funciona muy bien entonces cuando
regresemos a la clase de ciencia lo
vamos a pegar muy bien claro que sí
ese es tuyo sí a quien le guste arzu
dicho que levante la mano